dans votre livre relié à vous vous
évoquez vos relations tumultueuses avec
vos quatre maris c'était toujours très
très mal terminée il soit dans la
démence selon d'hystérie
alors
quatre sont vivants tous les quatre oui
ils vivent ensemble dans une satellite
on va voir ce à quoi vous seriez prête
par amour on va faire une interview par
amour
[Musique]
est-ce que par amour est-ce que par
amour vous accepteriez de vous couper
les cheveux non non
est-ce que par un mot pourriez vous
mettre au repassage
j'aime j'aime ça même sans abri d'accord
c'est ce que par amour vous pourriez
arrêter votre carrière non
parce que par leur amour vous pourriez
vivre sans sous vêtements non
ça à oui c'est vrai je fais l'amour dans
une chose comme ils sont deux je ne sais
pas de plonger ah bon
est-ce que par amour pour y renoncer au
sexe non
est-ce que par amour pour les remplacer
de sexe par la nourriture non est-ce que
par amon pourriez faire l'impasse sur
les préliminaires
non
non non je te prête à fait rien du tout
par amour vous avez du mal 4 c'est
d'avoir du mal à trouver un cinquième
mari
maintenant il sait tout aussi liane
cinquième il va savoir est-ce que par
amour vous pourriez accepté de jouer
dans un film pornographique non par
amour non si vous l'aimez non mais vous
l'aimez vraiment si vous l'aimez
vraiment nous ça nous ferait plaisir
alors d'accord est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez des gifles watts et armin
non non est-ce que par amour vous
pourriez vivre à seattle 6 watts
initiateurs
ouais non
c'est une ville cette ville ont dit ou
fallait avec l'enfer
est-ce que par amour vous pourriez
changer de religion ah non changez de
secte
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
une autre fille dans votre lit ces watts
quelqu'un qui voudrait le gazon par
l'emballage
non mais vous n'êtes rien attendez vous
acceptez rien d'être
là de soyaux hollande non est-ce que par
amour vous pourriez accepter un autre
garçon dans votre lit non
c'est toi qui fais attaquer les animaux
est-ce que par amour vous pourriez dire
des choses un peu sale en faisant
l'amour
midi le
oui alors quoi
est-ce que par amour pour les relancer à
tous vos amis non si c'est le vrai le
vrai amour
c'est le sait le moi si je cherche
quelque chose c'est le même a lorient on
relance rien parce qu'on est vraiment
amoureux
est-ce que par amour ou pourriez changer
de sexe bien ouais
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus